madame pécresse est ce que vous êtes
pour établir les ss voire le triplé mais
au moins le rétablir et qu'il y ait une
mesure de solidarité l'impôt de
solidarité sur la fortune et je rappelle
que quand il existe l isf en
2013 il devait y en avoir trois cent
quinze mille trois cent douze mille de
redevables alliès s allier sf et en 2017
il y en avait trois cent soixante mille
plus
ça toujours été un peu croissant ya
quasiment pas de départ à cause de l'
isf mais parce que en france ils sont du
gras gagne des sous a pas de problème
donc ils préfèrent payer lisf et ben moi
je suis certain qu ici en france ya des
riches qui sont prêts à payer les sf qui
sont prêts à le faire et apporter leur
contribution
parce qu'en période de guerre en période
de pandémie on doit tous tous faire un
effort madame pécresse
d'accord pour établir les sf alors
répondez lui s'il va repartir
alors moi moi je suis pas pour augmenter
les impôts voilà j'ai envie oui je suis
un homme et attend d être honnête tu
monsieur marcel je vous ai écouté vous
avez été rendu au camp et vous avez très
bien défendu cette france qui travaille
et moi je veux la défendre aussi parce
que travailler plus pour gagner plus
c'était effectivement le slogan de
nicolas sarkozy mais dans mon programme
aujourd'hui c'est je veux le travail qui
paye et le coeur de mon projet justement
c'est d'augmenter les salaires tous les
salaires dès le mois de juin tous les
salaires de tous ceux qui travaillent 2
3% en enlevant un tiers des cotisations
retraite et en prenant cet argent et
c'est l'état qui le financera et je veux
et ça veut dire que pour tous les
français qui travaillent aujourd'hui qui
vous l'avez dit ont été en première
ligne ils auront sur leur feuille de
paye une augmentation dès le mois de
juin parce que moi aussi monsieur
monsieur attendait tant d'être détendu
ou non là vraiment mission celle vous
êtes très sympathique mais je vous ai
écouté pendant dix
petites minutes petites minutes le 10
minutes moi je veux être la candidate de
la feuille de paye alors effectivement
effectivement quand on gagne 1400 euros
net aujourd'hui avec moi on aura 500
euros de salaire de plus sur un an et ça
commence en juin et puis je ferai une
grande conférence sociales et salariales
avec les syndicats et avec les
entreprises et je veux qu'on ait une
vraie stratégie pour augmenter les
salaires parce que vous l'avez dit le
coût de la vie explose et aujourd'hui le
pouvoir d'achat ne suit pas et donc on a
besoin aujourd'hui que les français
vivent dignement de leur salaire et
dignement de leur retraite parce que les
retraités ont été aussi les grands
oubliés du quinquennat d'emmanuel macron
mais pourquoi les retraités ont été les
grands oubliés parce qu emmanuel macron
n'a pas eu le courage de faire la
réforme des retraites on va en parler et
quand on fait pas de réforme eh bien on
n'a pas d'argent et quand on n'a pas
d'argent eh ben on peut pas indexer les
retraites sur l'inflation donc avec moi
les retraites elles sont indexées sur
l'inflation est avec moi on aura une
vraie réforme des retraites est une
vraie garantie pour que les retraités ne
perd pas en pouvoir d'achat mais sur les
salaires il n'ya pas seulement
l'augmentation des salaires il ya aussi
la possibilité de payer mieux les
fonctionnaires vous avez parlé des
fonctionnaires les fonctionnaires pour
pouvoir les payer mieux il faut de
l'argent là encore donc moi je serai la
réforme de l'état et j'aurai moins de
fonctionnaires mieux payés et dit je
veux qu'on puisse effectivement
travailler plus pour gagner plus si on
en a envie